but let's go back to the one thing i
asked you about earlier matt so this is
kind of this is kind of important
there were a lot of people who went to
the capitol on dc
uh in dc they went to the capitol on the
sixth and
they found their way inside the building
through no storming of anything
there's videos where the doors have been
opened and people were bumbling and
confused and walked in while the cops
nodded and dipped their hats
and even took selfies with them some of
these people are being charged with what
like misdemeanors
um pretty uh disorderly conduct on
capitol grounds
unlawful entry of a restricted building
and you know it goes beyond
just the charges themselves because
what what the effect of this is it's
destroying these people's lives um a
week ago
i sent on lookahead letterhead a letter
to the
acting attorney general and the fbi
director asking them to drop all charges
against
non-violent um basically trespassers
protesters who happen to find themselves
inside the capitol building
because this this is this is a political
persecution this isn't prop this isn't
just routine prosecution of crimes this
is persecution the level that the
federal government is going after these
people
and destroying their lives and the test
of it is simple is that
over and over again when the left did
this they repeatedly did this during
kavanaugh's
confirmation hearings they stormed the
buildings they
all of them yeah and they intimidated
senators they tried to interfere
with what the senate was doing all of
the people who were
who who did this were if they were
arrested at all
they were taken off site and given a
fine of 35 to 50
and let go to do it again but this
happens
and the reaction now granted i don't i'm
not talking about people who did true
violent actions or really tried to
destroy property
this is solely targeted the people who
happen to walk in and
all of these charges require something
called mens rea meaning you had to know
that it was a crime to do you had to
know you weren't allowed to go in there
into a building the public's routinely
allowed to on almost any given day of
the week outside of covet period right
it's a public building they walked in
they took some selfies they left and
this letter it's on lookaheadamerica.org
the website so i go through all the
legal arguments
but here's a problem and this occurred
to me as i was researching this
i spoke to multiple republican attorneys
one gentleman republican attorneys one
of the most prominent republican
attorneys in the entire country i said
well
you know is anybody helping these folks
out with attorneys because i'm hearing
some of them are getting trouble
and he told me that two problems number
one republican or conservative leaning
attorneys don't have a lot of practice
with rioters like the left does because
the left the aclu they're
they're on site they're wearing vests so
you know who they are
the right has no experience with this
but he said there's another problem
with taking these cases and he said
there's a problem with optics
then i talked to somebody else who was
working with a conservative law
professor
many of these people again they they
just walked into the building they
didn't know they were doing anything
wrong
they thought it was a peaceful protest
that's what got them in this trouble
um they this conservative law professor
is trying to
set them up with a legal representation
because these are serious charges
and he said that while there were
conservative leading attorneys who were
willing to take the cases
their law firm says told those attorneys
you are not allowed to take those cases
and it's been a real problem and you
know since i wrote this letter about
five or six of these individuals have
reached out to me and i have been able
to get them representation
but it just seems and here's the
contrast this is the one i mentioned
earlier that
um democrat-leaning white shoe firms in
dc were cheerleading their attorneys
going down to gitmo
to pro bono terrorists who set up bombs
killing civilians killing u.s troops to
represent them
and these people these boomers who
wandered through a building they
shouldn't have and took a selfie with a
cop smiling with them
are now facing pretty serious charges
and having their whole lives destroyed
can't get legal representation and
that's a that's absolutely abhorrent
republicans man sorry it's the
politicians
it's the leadership they are pathetic
spineless losers
it's just that simple they're they're
like i'd like to represent them you know
everyone deserves our day in court but
it's bad optics
okay so when you know antifa was burning
down
black lives matter was burning down
cities and kamala harris the current
vice president
tweeted let's raise money to get these
bail them out
people out of jail and they and i'm what
19 people is the official death council
it's actually substantially higher
how many people died during the riots
but as a direct result of righteous
action it's like 19.
you know there are cops who got shot and
paralyzed and kamala harris literally
can go on twitter and say
hey everybody give money to these people
who are committing acts of terrorism
and a republican goes that that bumbling
dotard of an old woman
she can't have a lawyer now now just to
make it clear you know
at trump's inauguration over 200 people
were arrested for
violence like assaulting police officers
burning cars burning
police cars they all had their charges
dropped
all dropped and and here's what
perplexes and this is what frustrates me
most i i run look at america it's a
voter registration organization right
why am i the one that has to write this
letter huh like
why i'm just some you know you know a
few you
have helped us out by bringing publicity
to it a few others um have as well but
like where's the the republican
political leadership
standing up these are their people i
think i think you just
explained it very simply by uttering an
oxymoron republican leadership
i'm sorry it doesn't work you look at
what mitch mcconnell was doing
you know were any of these republicans
fighting for you know what
just outside of impeachment outside of
trump outside of this
when do they fight for anything their
constituents actually want other than
just tell people
no wait don't there was only one guy who
ever did that
and was that trump the president yeah i
mean he
look many fair criticism but he never
sent anybody's
son off into a war that he started yep
he sent a lot of drones we have this
article from the hill i want to i want
to pull this up murkowski
i don't know how trump could be elected
again oh murkowski please
people look that's what i tweeted you
give someone the option between a ham
sandwich in you and a lot of people are
gonna take it
you you put up donald trump who's like
i'm gonna fight for you and fight for
these
things a lot more people are going to
take it that's why the guy won in the
first place
he increased the amount of votes he
received the second time around by what
10 million more than 10 million right
it was like 10 or 11 million i think
maybe more historic
and that was the most votes a sitting
president ever got into history
in history yeah yeah so and then joe
biden of course the greatest president
who's ever lived
sent to just a ripple wave of charisma
and energy
across this nation that's really
inspired everybody garnering the most
votes we've ever seen
of any candidate ever a remarkable man
his youtube page definitely reflects it
it's true there might be signs of a
trend that there are just more voters
more activated voters now since that's
exactly it look
early on ian you mentioned that there
was more news
and i was i've been talking to a lot of
people during the election
there were a ton of people i knew who
had no business in politics like
just literally have never been involved
and they were so active and they knew
everything
and now they're gone once again talking
about nonsensical bs
you know and i i shouldn't be that mean
they're talking about just you know
hokey stuff the movie they went and saw
and
how their friend you know spilled a beer
last night and it's just normal stuff
but during the election it was like
trump is a fascist we must stop him yeah
and everyone was cheering and dancing
and that was one of the most one of one
of these strategies
of the democrats on the left in terms of
getting new votes is making it a
cultural movement
so that really did help it doesn't help
when the candidate they were voting for
is this like bumbling old dodard who you
know you can't really understand when he
yells chewing on a shop and a pressure
but whatever it's interesting time to
say the least
i think they took something seriously
that the right has never taken
seriously which is voter registration
you know
putting a psych there's issues of
illegal ballots we're not going to talk
about that but
after the election in georgia i went
down in canvas neighborhoods
entire neighborhoods that stacey abrams
with the help of
massive millions of dollars from people
like zuckerberg went down
and registered to vote new voters and
turned them out
and on our side um and i say this is a
non-profit on the patriotic side
there's nobody doing that i mean that's
what i'm trying to do with look ahead
but
um that when people look at those
astounding numbers
i used to go to a big meeting of all the
people on the right
okay non-profit some partisan groups
once a week in dc it's a very famous
meeting i'm not going to name check it
but every year at the beginning of the
year i would get up and read the
statistics of
in key states these are the number of
new democrats registered these are
number new republicans registered and
the democrats every year
it was a substantially higher number in
all these swing states higher and higher
higher i would get and these are very
the white house would be at this meeting
both houses of congress
and i would get up i would give that
little talk i walk into the lobby so
people could come chat with me
nobody cared nobody paid any attention
because they're all focused on you know
whatever was hot at the moment or
you know some minor controversy that was
long forgotten
but those are the things that pay
dividends in the long run
the left has been doing it for and
you're right to point it out the left
has been doing it for a very long time
they're not only organized politically
with fundraising
and with getting out the vote they're
organized in terms of the ability to
riot and have legal observers present
they understand when they go and write
destroy things they wear masks these
these trump people who enter the capitol
building were like smiling and waving
for cameras just totally oblivious to
what was going on yeah a really
interesting insurrection where
in a country where everybody can or does
have an ar
they didn't bring any karate style
insurrection right open hands well not
even that the smiling bumbling and
respecting the velvet ropes
when donald trump was being inaugurated
250 or so individuals got arrested
most mostly wearing all black and
smashing windows and starting fires
and the police had no real way to charge
anyone
because they were wearing masks so what
did they do they said conspiracy
and the judge said are you nuts wearing
a hoodie and a mask in public is not
evidence of a conspiracy
and they tried arguing it was because
you know what they were doing we all
know what they were doing but at a legal
standard
they didn't have enough and these people
all basically got released except for
those who played pleaded guilty
yeah they took plea agreements where's
the aclu on this
i mean i i know it's the left i know
what they're tweeting i know that
they're partisan but
historically they represented i mean
correct me if i'm wrong individuals in
groups like the kkk
they fought for important values for
free speech for everyone regardless of
that speech and now they're
they're tweeting about genders and you
would think but but this is important
here
but this is very critically important
for them to understand this because this
is essentially a right to regress a
right to protest
that's going to be used as a way to stop
other protests in the future and if you
care about protesting if you care about
speech
if you care about this huge hammer
coming down on a group of individuals
whether you like them or you don't like
them
yes there are some bad apples yes there
were some bad events yes there was some
violence it all gets
deserved to be called out but but
essentially they're setting a president
here
that that's going to be very dangerous
for them in the future as of course
predictively as i've been saying the the
biden administration is going to use
this orwellian power
not just on the right but on the left
very soon as well when have they ever
learned
about how it comes back for them they've
been they've been demanding censorship
for years
and now youtube is cracking down on
progressive youtubers yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you